[Musica]
un tempo aveva un metodo per ricaricarmi
prendevo uno zaino un sacco a pelo un
bis un biglietto del treno che mi
portasse fuori dalla città e poi
cominciavo a camminare a camminare fino
a lasciarmi dietro tutto e tutti
fino ad arrivare davanti alle onde del
mare a un deserto o una foresta
poi una volta lì mi mettevo a guardare
il paesaggio in silenzio cercavo di
ascoltarlo quindi mi sdraiavo per terra
dormivo per terra dormivo quel che
riuscivo
la mattina dopo mi svegliavo con la
schiena rotta e mi rimetteva in cammino
sulla strada del ritorno verso verso il
rumore verso la civiltà verso gli altri
e sulla strada del ritorno quella quel
silenzio si faceva parola anzi parole
che trascrivevo sul mio quaderno sulle
note del telefono mentre mi passava
davanti il mondo tra la mia fuga e la
mia vita ed era quello il momento in cui
capivo capivo di essermi ricaricato
perché il mio mestiere
il nostro mestiere parlando per i
colleghi e anche e soprattutto quello di
cercare e trovare parole e sentirsi
carichi vuol dire riuscire a trovarle
più facilmente riuscire a illuminarle
quando ci passano davanti o meglio
dietro agli occhi e quindi i viaggi di
ritorno i finestrini diventano uno dei
momenti di massima produttività possono
essere il finestrino di un aereo che sta
tornando dai deserti dell'america e sta
passando sopra alle risaie attorno
malpensa o può essere il finestrino di
un interregionale lanciato diciamo a
media velocità lungo la pianura padana
di ritorno da venezia dopo una notte
sulle fondamenta 9 a guardare a guardare
la laguna piccoli o grandi isolamenti
per cercare di sentire meglio
distinguere meglio le voci che si hanno
dentro distinguere meglio le parole
questo era il mio metodo funzionava lo
sponsorizzava anche con i miei colleghi
o con i miei amici dicendo fatelo anche
voi perché pensavo che potesse
funzionare funzionare con tutti ho
provato nell'ultimo anno e mezzo a
ripeterlo appena ho potuto e ogni volta
che ho potuto partivo camminavo arrivato
davanti a un bosco al mare ma trovavo un
silenzio nuovo un silenzio sterile un
silenzio del giorno dopo non lasciava
nessun tipo di residuo semplicemente non
funzionava più
ora io sono nato nel 1982 sono un
perfetto millennio la definizione sono
un target ideale per operazioni
nostalgia diciamo e sono andato e
cresciuto in una società che
semplicemente aveva già perso ogni
speranza sulla collettività su progetti
che coinvolgessero veramente gli altri i
miei i nostri genitori ci avevano
provato più o meno convintamente ma
erano andati incontro a si può dire
cocenti delusioni il mondo in cui sono
cresciuto mi diceva che bisognava
puntare sull'individuo sul singolo che
l'energia l'energia di cui stiamo
parlando che potete chiamare anche
felicità potete chiamare pace e serenità
verità addirittura che questa energia
era nascosta dentro di noi che in
qualche modo dovevamo rovistarci dentro
per per trovarla nella sua variante per
usare un'espressione del dell'epoca new
age queste energie era anche contenuta
appunto nel sole nella luna nel mare nel
deserto e nelle foreste ma in modo per
arrivarci passava sempre in qualche modo
da una strada che attraversava il se
effettivamente l'unica l'unico attore
che non era previsto
in questa ricerca in questo processo
erano gli altri il resto dell'umanità
non era considerato mai effettivamente
necessario per arrivare a questa energia
o verità di cui dicevamo
ora l'ultimo anno e mezzo tutti quanti
abbiamo provato abbiamo sperimentato un
isolamento chi con il mare davanti chi
senza chi con qualcuno di fianco chi
senza mai stato un isolamento che ci ha
tolto giorno dopo giorno energia invece
che dar cina ci hanno detto ci siamo
detti di andarsela appunto cercare
dentro di noi di andarla a cercare nei
libri nella musica nei film
nell'auto analisi nella meditazione
nella psicanalisi nella cucina
addirittura nell'attività fisica che
cosa abbiamo trovato veramente io
personalmente ho avuto tutto il tempo
per ascoltare tutta la musica del mondo
a un modico prezzo tra l'altro per
ascoltare tutta la musica del mondo l'ho
fatto
no da grande amante del cinema avuto
tutto il tempo per vedere tutti i
capolavori che avrei che ancora mi
mancavano l'ha fatto no anzi per il film
e in particolare per le finzioni
ho sentito una crescente antipatia quasi
quasi una repulsione e le parole le
parole che ho scritto in questione e
mezzo mi sono sembrate avere meno luce
forse addirittura tutte le parole che
sono state scritte in questo anno e
mezzo avevano poca luce erano con me
come fiammiferi che riescono illuminare
a squarciare il buio soltanto per pochi
secondi giusto il tempo di riprendere un
attimo la strada la verità e credo che
l'umanità non aveva mai provato prima
d'ora l'esperienza di vivere senza
l'umanità stessa certo un vivere che è
stato un vivere surrogato il vivere che
ci è stato permesso dalle tecnologie che
abbiamo inventato e portato avanti ma
questo cosa vuol dire
cambiando prospettiva vuol dire che
prima che le esperienze di prima ogni
esperienza aveva dentro di sé una specie
di variabile invisibile qualcosa che non
vedevamo che erano effettivamente gli
altri quindi quando io partivo quando
raggiungevo i posti più remoti per sarli
da solo non mi rendevo conto di avere di
fianco a me insieme a me invisibile il
resto dell'umanità e forse era così per
tutti e per tutti per tutti gli artisti
in cerca di ispirazione per tutti i
solitari ma addirittura per anche per
gli scienziati accampati sulle scogliere
a studiare i pinguini questo in realtà
stavamo facendo stavamo partendo
fuggendo con il permesso del resto
dell'umanità
eravamo in missione per loro erano loro
a mandarci da qualche parte per andare a
cercare trovare e raccontare e poi
tornare tornare dire che cosa avevamo
cercato che cosa avevano trovato anche
solo che cosa avevamo sentito ma questo
vuol dire che e qui parlo per noi noi
cantautori noi artisti che ci sentiamo
così intrecciati al nostro ego al nostro
bisogno di esprimerci la nostra voglia
di parlare anche quando nessuno ce lo
chiede questo vuol dire che l'unico
destinatario o se vogliamo essere più
concreti l'unico datore di lavoro di
tutta questa espressione sono loro sono
gli altri non c'è nient'altro e quindi
noi che ci siamo sentiti così inutili in
questo anno e mezzo
perché inutile eravamo effettivamente il
punto non è cambiare quello che stavamo
facendo
continuiamo a farlo continuiamo a fare
queste benedette inutili canzoni ma
continuiamo a farlo
rendendoci conto che avrà senso soltanto
finché le considereremo un gesto un dare
uno slancio verso gli altri questo è
veramente l'unico senso
e ricordiamoci anche che negli altri in
questi altri di questo parlando
sono compresi anche tutti quelli che
abbiamo accusato che abbiamo indicato
che abbiamo in questo anno e mezzo
incolpato di quello che stava succedendo
tutti quelli che abbiamo schivato sui
marciapiedi anche ancora scriviamo tutti
quelli che scriviamo nelle corsie dei
supermercati sono loro effettivamente il
destinatario ultimo unico di quello che
stiamo facendo
sono loro misteriosi splendidi
detestabili ma necessari credo che
semplicemente la fuori loro ci stiano
aspettando e vicendevolmente
ci stiamo aspettando grazie
tu
[Musica]